[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by sophia rosinski
aka mac who stars and paper girls which
is out now on prime video we're gonna
talk spoilers so make sure you watch the
full season first then watch this
interview how you doing today sophia
doing very well thank you for having me
oh no thank you for coming on the show
i'm really excited to talk to you and i
think one of the first questions i
always have for people that are new to
the scene and is exciting is you're
playing such an awesome character of mac
but were you always going to play mac or
did you ever audition for anybody else
as well
for me it was only it was only mac i was
the last one of the girls to be cast so
i think while i was going through my
auditioning process all of the other
girls had already been cast so mac was
the only one i ever went out for
oh no and it's perfect like you
absolutely embody the part so really
really awesome job on your part and
did you also find a lot of yourself in
the character of mac or was it more
different
oh i would say that mac and i have some
similarities but most of i think we
mainly have differences um
i would say one of our similarities
being uh humor
we always manage to make a joke right at
the time that you probably shouldn't be
making a joke
and
yeah i would say that i would i would
say mainly humor would be something that
we have in common yeah and mac really
does have great like wit humor to her
character and
are you excited too because you're on a
project that's off a big comic series
like i'm sure there's going to be mac
funko pops coming out action figures
like does all this excite you in doing
conventions and stuff like that
yeah yeah i mean um coming up will be
comic-con and i've never done a
comic-con before
got even just been to one so i'm i'm
really excited for it very excited for
it
yeah that must be thrilling and
it's cool too i want to just also talk
about some big moments in the season
finale of the show there is a moment
where
mac puts her hand on kj's hand in the
barn can you kind of run through me what
was
mac feeling maybe in that moment how you
kind of read that
right so the way i interpreted it was
something along the lines of um
she's not really sure
what exactly friends
do to show appreciation to the other one
so she's probably just thinking is is
this
how you
yeah okay i'll do this
um
i think she she means as like a nice
friendly gesture um
but of course
kind of
there are two different interpretations
of what that meant
and um i think in the moment mac is just
trying to find a way to
show her gratitude for kj being so
so helpful and kind to her
yeah that's a great answer and i think
what people are going to love about this
season and stand out is the relationship
between mac and kj and how that kind of
evolves um
what was your favorite moment would you
say the season anything kind of stick
out to you that you love maybe even just
filming
um
i i loved working i loved working with
um
i love the scenes between the paper
girls i think that those are those are
fantastic and
um the scenes between
um
around episode three i think maybe one
of my favorites
favorite episodes um working with an
actor named cliff chamberlain
was just incredible and
um
i was very glad to have the opportunity
to work with an actor um such as himself
he was very generous and giving
that's great and uh
i i also have a question too before i
let you go what do you hope
to see happen possibly with mac in a
possible season too like is there
anything you kind of hope maybe where
her story might go
hmm
i'm
i'm looking forward to seeing
i would be looking forward to seeing i
guess mac
just kind of
i don't know i think
i think that in the first in the first
season already she has such a
spectacular arc
you know much like in the comic book
series and
i'm looking forward to see her seeing
her go even further with that and
change and become a completely different
person than she starts out at the
beginning of the series as
yeah i can't wait to and everybody make
sure to watch paper girls now
on prime video and just watch sofia kill
it as mac here you do such an amazing
job and bring this character to life
sophia thank you so much for joining me
today and i hope to talk to you in the
future one day thank you steve thank you